here we go in five four three two one
what's poppin you crazy [ __ ] hi
they always crazy [ __ ] because
it's open I think you know what's
interesting I found out recently through
Muriel that she says I have a problem
with complimenting her oh really
well she's a verbal affirmation person
okay which of which I do understand yeah
like verbal affirmation or whatever but
I am I wish that she was an active
service person because I'm very good at
active service yeah for example the
other day she was telling me that so we
were walking and she was having a bad
day and when she's having a bad day like
number one I I like listening yeah when
somebody's having a bad day but she
wants me to be involved in that
conversation give her eye contact and
all that other stuff yeah that's not my
forte yeah your forte is listening right
so despite the fact that I talk a lot
it's different when it's like a
one-on-one conversation with somebody
because usually when somebody has
problems they just want to talk it out
and they want to figure it out
themselves exactly so what I've learned
to do is just let them speak and then
maybe I'll say a few words here and
there because I mean what's really what
what really am I gonna say that they
don't already know yeah is how I feel
anyways right but with hurts a little
different it's like she actually wants
me to be engaged to talk to her so it
stumps me yeah so she goes what do you
think and I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm like well
I don't know like you know I mean I just
usually have people just talking out and
they just figured it out themselves
right and so for her like I figured out
that I'm for me and she's like well you
don't really you're not really engaging
and you're not really giving me the
stuff that I need and I'm like well
technically I guess because I'm not
really giving her the love language that
she likes yeah cuz I'm an active service
person so for example before she came in
I already made her dinner so she could
she could go ahead eat that whenever and
then I also prepared her lunch for
tomorrow for for work yeah so I'm like
pretty decent boyfriend yeah but that's
not how she she cares and that's the
thing it's that once those acts of
service kind of become standard then
it's easy to kind of forget that oh they
went out of their way to do the
for me and be mindful of like my
schedule or like what I need yeah but I
think when there is that difference
though because I had that problem to
where you know past relationships well
it's a pretty common theme for me is
that I've always been told I'm like a
robot I'm not very emotional and for me
I'm an action person too so it was
always be like focus on the actions
right not so much the words because I
haven't really been good at that too
yeah I'm just being a little bit more I
guess verbal with with my affection and
my emotions I just yeah I just didn't
grow up like that you know what I mean I
didn't grow up in a family where it was
like oh I love you and we give each
other hugs and kisses like you just
understood that you're loved and the
only time he got affection is that my
face I didn't get that I didn't get that
soft you know type of a family type of
love so I just grew up a little bit
hardened and as a result of that it kind
of shaped me you know for me I grew up
with a lot of that love and hug stuff so
I'm going physical with my life okay
I'll give people hugs whatever whatnot
we'll play grab-ass whatever you want
whatever let's make it happen
yeah and so I'll do all that stuff but
when it comes to actually verbally like
for example for her she wants verbal
affirmation in the sense of when she
does something she wants me to say good
job you're doing great okay yes thank
you for doing that yeah and that's what
she wants but it doesn't come to my mind
so for example like she I noticed this
about her that she the reason why she
likes verbal affirmation so much is
because her dad talks her up like a
[ __ ] oh so we were swimming at
her place with her dad yeah her family
and stuff and then Mariel at her
grandma's place at her swimming pool
she's climbing this like rock formation
that they have at the swimming thing
mm-hmm
so she's climbing up and then she looks
at her dad this is by the way like a 28
year old woman there she goes she looks
at her - she goes dad look at me look at
me aren't I doing a good job and her
dad's like you're doing a great job
awesome I hold on a second you're damn
near 30 what the [ __ ] is going on and
they're right when I saw that I was like
well that's
that's why from yeah that's why she cuz
her dad still does it for her so that's
what she grew up with I see so for me I
don't really do that yeah she's climbing
rocks I'm like alright [ __ ] you know
just don't die hey I'm like yo I'm not
like your climbing rocks it she'll look
at me and I'm just like cool what do you
want from me what do you want me to say
ya know so far I'm learning to kind of
give her compliments for stuff in my
mind yeah that doesn't seem like [ __ ]
right but for her it's a big deal not I
mean I I see how that has become like a
big factor for in her life if her dad
has been like that - oh yeah since she
was a kid but you know that's kind of
part of the relationship right even
though you guys have been together for a
while still the process of learning each
other's nuances and the things that
really make them tick and the things
that they enjoy or don't enjoy and then
within that trying to find some sort of
middle ground or even trying to go past
that middle line up and then do more for
them as a result because like there's
this saying it's like in a relationship
you should always feel like you're doing
60% and and not expecting that in return
but just trying to do more for this
person because you actually want to and
you love them right and hopefully as a
result of that it'll inspire them and
there will be some sort of reciprocation
and both parties are trying to give 60%
or more yeah but it should never be this
like oh yeah I'm right at the halfway
point so I'm doing enough yeah it should
be like I want to do more for this
person yeah
relationships are so difficult like I'm
trying yeah you know for us too you know
what the cool thing is is that I feel
like a lot of the you know when I when I
tell these stories about Muriel's
[ __ ] up like people are so funny to
goes they'll be like oh why are you
still with her then I'm like you don't
[ __ ] fight with your significant
other you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag like you've
never ever had a disagreement with your
partner yeah and you know I'll be it
like I'll tell these stories because
number one they're funny yeah and number
two I'm not gonna tell you a story about
how things were just okay and no
exactly it's not exactly I think when
that happens it's and it's different for
you because your social media
personality yeah I know you talk about
your life and you talk about problems or
like you know things that are going well
for you whatever right and so when it
comes to relationship things like you
said like the things that are kind of
going wrong tends to be a little bit
more funnier yes of course I'm gonna
exaggerate and highlight yeah yeah all
right and so I sometimes like people
will message me they go you know what
like I don't understand like you guys
would probably break up and I'm like I
okay yeah I came an expert on a
relationship
yeah right so you're an expert in my
relationship so like you've heard six
fights that we had over four-and-a-half
years yeah whoa well I get the whole
picture that were fighting all the time
six fights in four and a half years like
Jesus I think I think the thing that
people tend to forget is that they're
[ __ ] bags the [ __ ] that gets left over in
the condiment thrown away ya know but
it's when you're talking about that that
becomes kind of magnified and they don't
recognize that oh they have been
together for this long though
so there must be very good aspects of
the relationship for it to have gone
this long of course but they don't think
about that they're just thinking about
what they're hearing and and reacting to
that immediately being like oh damn yes
because people don't realize you only
get a small excerpt and people only show
you what they want to show you yeah
you're never ever gonna get the full
picture and so absolutely they have this
bias when they see for example like
celebrity couples and they hear or see
these interviews where they they get
into a fight and then they break up
later they go see I already knew it so
it's their own confirmation bias and it
gasses them up saying like oh now I'm a
fortune-teller relationships you don't
you don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] exact that's
that well here's the thing it's one
thing to look at that as entertainment I
got no problem with that but then to
feel like you know these people now
because of what you're seeing and you
don't have Lloyd's on social media it's
crazy to me it's like why are you so
involved in their life like why do you
care what ariana grande is doing why do
you care what Kim Kardashian's doing
what do you care about Justin Bieber's
don't lay it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter to you I read this comment the
other day too because I so basically
recently I gave up my Tesla so I had a
couple of months left on the lease and
because I moved into a new spot I
decided that I just didn't need an extra
card I want to pay for an extra parking
space yeah you know it was about time
like number one like the reason why I
had that car was wasn't it was stupid
like I just wanted to have something
nice that I wanted when I was a kid and
I couldn't afford story and I thought it
would fulfill a certain part of my life
that would make me feel better like I
would look back on this thing and say yo
it's tired when I gave it up I was like
[ __ ] get out of my face you [ __ ]
trash piece of [ __ ] $1,100 a month dude
yeah that's ridiculous you know but
somebody wrote this comment they go oh
oh oh you're doing the right thing
unlike some of your other friends like
you know Barton stuff they're buying all
these nice things that's not responsible
I said well first of all you don't know
what he's spending on and how much money
he has left right so in terms of what's
important to him is different from me
yeah so if Bart says he's making X
amount of money and he could afford that
and do everything else then who's to say
yeah and if he's a car person then that
value makes sense for him he could look
back at that car and say you know what
this car makes me happy when I Drive it
is the way for me to relieve stress and
when I look back on this vehicle is more
than just a vehicle to me exactly for me
it's not yeah I mean if you worked that
hard and you have success especially in
the form of money right you get to
choose how you want to spend that money
you know what I mean
and if if you want to spend it
irresponsibly I mean yeah sure that's
not the best thing but it's still your
[ __ ] money
you have to spend it however you want
but that's an interesting about
interesting thing about social media now
it's that when people see this
it's almost or actually automatically an
open invitation to tell you or whoever
they're looking at what they think and
their thoughts on the matter and it's
like why don't you spend that energy and
focus it on yourself you know what I
mean yo so it's and it's interesting too
because in that case when when they when
they talk about stuff like that they
also have to realize that number one
when when when I wrote that thing it
wasn't me making
it wasn't me saying how everybody else
should value that things in their life
yeah it's my life your personal
experience actually so what you learned
so people think like oh suddenly when I
say sub me they think that shoe should
fit for everybody I'm talking about my
personal experience and what I learned
what you what you take from it is
whatever you take from it it's like this
like for example like you'll hear people
say well I had this bad situation with
you know a guy or a girl and they go you
know what [ __ ] man ate [ __ ] what do
you mean men dude you and that
individual person is a piece of [ __ ]
yeah don't [ __ ] bring this whole
other gender thing with it yeah and
that's like the hottest thing on Twitter
right now they go man ain't [ __ ] and so
the other day one of my friends wrote oh
it was a very specific situation like oh
how are you gonna go and start tweeting
people behind people's backs blah blah
blah blah and at the end she wrote , men
ain't [ __ ] and I wrote back to her and I
was like well you know you know those
girls that [ __ ] go around [ __ ] and
dude on the side but still have the
maenge I pay for all of their money I
guess women are a bunch of hoes then
yeah but you can't make that
generalization man but I just feel like
they it's an emotional response you know
what I mean get it there they're not
logically and reasonably thinking about
it and I think what irritates me more is
not when they make that statement but
when you I guess elaborate on it and
kind of give them more perspective but
then now they realize okay I shouldn't
generalize but they're too stubborn or
they're too egotistical to be like yeah
you're right yeah it's the nah men
stealing [ __ ] [ __ ] man yeah and also too
if you're that [ __ ] girl that gets
together with [ __ ] 12 or even guy
that gets together with 12 trash bags
maybe your [ __ ] selection choice is a
little flawed right right so if every
guy that you've been with or girls that
you've been with has even either used
you for money or have cheated on you
maybe you suck maybe your choices aren't
the best yeah maybe you shouldn't get
the guy with 17 face tattoos yeah that
barely knows how to [ __ ] read what's
your problem dude what did you expect
right exactly and if you haven't learned
okay if you're young you're gonna make
mistakes that's a given
but time and time again as you get older
you keep picking the same type of girl
or same type of guy that you've had
within the past yeah and then you keep
wondering why the [ __ ] are all men are
all women like this and you keep
wondering why the [ __ ] can I not meet
somebody good it's like have you looked
in the [ __ ] mirror because if because
if all men are women are trash at that
point and how come your other colleagues
around you have found somebody very
special so maybe you keep on fishing for
tin cans and you're wondering why it's
not a [ __ ] fish [ __ ] yo before we get
into the main topic though oh the main
topic we're bringing up some [ __ ] so
it's a very current [ __ ] we're gonna get
into this quick little uh sponsored ad
real quick so uh let's dive into that
all right can I tell you guys something
can I tell you what this genius brain
podcast is brought to you by I think
it's Skillshare multiple notes for no
damn reason so if you guys don't know
what Skillshare is Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
creativity and career so basically what
I'm saying is that if you have a new
passion out there you have a side hustle
that you want to start or begin this is
a great way to go at it Skillshare
basically gives you that knowledge at
your [ __ ] finger tips my
friends so for me the classes that I'm
taking right now specifically have to do
with photography because photography is
something that I like to do on the side
and because I did it through an
apprenticeship back in the day there's a
lot of I guess you could say like
fundamental basics that I don't know and
going through these courses helped me
out and it kind of adheres to the way
that I like to learn which is on my own
time so a lot of the times when you go
through traditional courses or classes
sometimes it's a little derived and it
doesn't teach you the things that you
want to learn what was skill sure it has
like your own library and you could you
know fast forward or rewind or learn
however the hell you want so that's why
I [ __ ] with Skillshare a lot so remember
people join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners you get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
there's two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
brain to start your two months now that
is Skillshare dot-com slash brain when
you guys are on there and let me know
the courses that you're taking if you
like it let me know in the comments
below because you know what I've [ __ ]
with it I'm using it and trust me people
my photo skills is getting up there
skill Shey anyways we're back and
today's topic is gonna be interesting
I've been looking up a lot of like
current events [ __ ] number one I'm very
disconnected from the world I think a
lot of the stuff that I am finding out
is just it has to be either on a
headline or somebody has to bring it to
my attention so if people are going to
message me about it like consistently
then I'll talk about it so have you
heard about this whole like Johnny Depp
and Amber Heard thing aren't they
divorce yeah so a couple of years ago I
guess they got divorced there was this
whole [ __ ] about like domestic violence
right I think that whatever settled out
of court or Minar but recently I guess
Amber Heard she has been coming out to
light as this s4 like to me to movement
she was getting interviewed by something
or somebody and she kind of alluded to
the fact that she's a domestic abuse
survivor and for Jon and you know and
that kind of gets out of hand and people
were trashing Johnny Depp because I
can't believe you abused Amber Heard or
whatever and if you don't know who Amber
Heard is she's an actress and Johnny
Depp is firing back like he's not gonna
sit there and take it yeah and so for
him he was saying like no like you can't
just capitalize off this me to movement
and she's trying to gain a lot of clout
from that yeah and it he actually has
documentation and that's coming out
they're saying the exact opposite Wow
where she actually physically abused him
okay I'm talking about there's like
documents like just stating that she
like punched him in his sleep in his
sleep yeah like stalked him in his sleep
in a people remember there was his time
where Johnny had Johnny Depp had a
severed finger oh yeah a severed finger
he had a severed finger and I guess
prior to this people were
it was stated that he did it in a fit of
rage or something like she and him got
into an argument or some sort but what
happened at what actually happened I
guess like what's being told now is that
she actually chucked the vodka bottle at
him coach it and when she chucked the
vodka bottle at him it's it exploded and
severed his [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that's like
some [ __ ] you can't even make up you
know and I'm telling you this number one
no dude wants to come out and say you
know what I got beat up by the prettiest
girl on earth right you know like I
think it's very I think that's the
reason why a lot of male domestic
violence violence cases does they don't
come out yeah because it's it's almost
same felucca yeah see that's what's not
fair is like you know the whole me to
movement and like women exposing men in
power who are abusing their power just
shitty men in general is is a great
thing right they should be exposed and
they should be called out and have to
pay the price for whether what they did
but why isn't it just as important the
other way around right because still in
society it's it's very emasculating to
talk about stuff like that it's not
looked at as oh yeah we should we should
treat both issues on an equal plane yeah
it's but you're a guy like yeah how can
you have been abused by a girl it's like
mental abuse right physical abuse
getting your dick chopped off abuse
right above it abuse um I mean come on
man it happens but people kind of brush
it off like it's not that big of a deal
or not doesn't really happen you know
because men are supposed to be stronger
or whatever so - like Johnny Depp's case
listen to this [ __ ] so this is this is
from his lawyer yeah
miss hurts false allegations against mr.
Depp had been conclusively refuted by
two separate responding police officers
a litany of neutral third party
witnesses and eighty-seven newly
obtained surveillance camera videos so
she was talking about so there was like
a case like I'm trying to look for it
right now but there was a point where I
guess Amber Heard was screaming like
Johnny stop hitting me or don't hit me
or something to that right but there was
like a security officer like a couple
steps away and they're like what the
[ __ ] he's not even hitting you so she's
I'm punching him in the face
Johnny stop
do you know oh man so unaware that
members of mr. Depp secured him were
mere feet away misheard falsely began
yelling stop hitting me Johnny to the
interaction the interaction culminated
with misheard making false allegations
that mr. Depp struck her with the
cellphone hit her and destroyed the
penthouse there were multiple
eyewitnesses to this hoax so I guess it
was on multiple occasions she's done
this [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] man do man girl
like there are some girls that are
[ __ ] crazy yo I was so in Sacramento
there was this dude now mind you it's
kind of connected in two separate
stories but I'm just gonna give a couple
of back I mentioned this on just kidding
used before but there was a dude I'm not
gonna say his name cuz that fool my
father killed me but let's just say in
high school I remember was I being a
hyper hyper violent dude this girl not
not the girl that I'm gonna talk about
later she's a very sweet girl well I
went to our high school she was like a
class above me but she used to go out
with this guy let's call him Billy I'm
just gonna call him Billy so she used to
go out with his do Billy right Billy got
kicked out of school he was like a
hardcore gangbanger the new was pub like
4 foot 10 you know yet he had like
little Manson okay but I specifically
remember this fool walking up on campus
and socking this girl in the face for
what because they were together I don't
know what the reason cuz I didn't really
know the dude like that yeah but they do
walked up and he socked this girl string
in her [ __ ] nose it was in the middle
of the the [ __ ] area where we were
having a lunch
yeah just walks up to her and just boom
uh-huh socks are in the nose and this
was after school but socks him it socks
are the [ __ ] nose and blood starts
gushing out yeah but you know there are
cases of this like this domestic violent
rife have seen men physically abuse
women
yeah but on the other hand there was
this other time where I remember this
other dude that I knew by the way when I
say no he's not my friend
yeah just somebody you you know high
school you know a tourist for being you
know very terrible things but he went
out with this other girl I don't know
who this girl is but she did the classic
like
my last boyfriend beat me up hit me type
of [ __ ] and so what I heard from a
couple of other people this is obviously
wasn't there yeah but that dude and his
whole crew went to jail because she told
a lie to that guy that that got her
previous ex-boyfriend her previous
boyfriend was beating the [ __ ] out of
her huh
so they [ __ ] executioner styled
killed that fool
Wow like in the driveway yeah like
straight up surrounded him in the
driveway and had him on his knees and
[ __ ] blasted the dude in the head
because of a lie that she told she told
that she was getting abused by him she
actually went to I think she went she's
like in prison for like 25 years to life
yeah and everybody else got like 10 or
15 years or something unless it was a
less was it called sentence yeah cuz she
was like the ringleader uh-huh but
everybody in that circle because of that
one girl's lie all went to jail yeah so
that's what I'm saying like you can't
just take everybody's award for
everything right cuz that dude
first of all you're [ __ ] dumb in the
first place like just let's say she was
abused right the the the the the right
action isn't to go and shoot somebody
execute in the middle of a driveway two
out of all places couldn't you have done
it somewhere that wasn't as public yeah
I mean or just give him a little beating
or something Jesus yeah you know yeah
but the dude
they said that he shot the [ __ ]
I don't know if it was him but he was
one of those dudes that that was in that
circle that beat the [ __ ] I was shot him
like while he was like on his knees or
some [ __ ] ya know you know what that
reminds me of man is reminds me of
Anthony Bourdain situation right like
hey what was his girl's name I can't
remember you know but she was like a
kind of like a spokesperson for the me
to movement to not a spokesperson but
she was really speaking out on her past
the situations especially with Harvey
Weinstein right but I remember reading
about it that she accused him of I don't
know sexual abuse or rape or something
like that yeah but then she kept
sleeping with him even after the fact
right of the alleged time of when this
happened right not to say that Harvey
Weinstein didn't do any of the stuff
that he's been accused for but she kept
sleeping with him after a certain point
so it's like
how do you accuse somebody of doing that
to you but then you go back have
consensual sex after yeah yeah right
and then how she's she was such a active
voice for that me to movement and
Anthony Bourdain really supported her
and backed her up too but then it comes
out that she might have actually
sexually abused that that
seventeen-year-old Oh she was uh she was
either an actress or a casting director
what was she
i I don't know but but the guy was
underage at the time that they had sex I
remember II was like on a boat or some
[ __ ] to and it was like on her yacht or
something I forgot what it was yeah you
know I will say this though 17:17 well
I'm only saying this right or wrong but
I'm only speaking from from a 17 year
old boys perspective yeah when I'm 17
I'm a [ __ ] adult right and if there's
a [ __ ] fresh vagina being slung at me
I'm not thinking that I'm underaged I'm
thinking yo I'm an adult
yeah I'm taking Plus a life yeah yeah
yeah well I mean that's that's from the
the boys perspective but from her
standpoint she should know better you
know did the boy feel like he was he was
taking advantage of yeah yeah he came
out about that saying yeah yeah well I'm
talking about 17 year old David 70 year
old David was a different person
like if somebody first of all nobody
would touch 70 no name so if any woman
said hey let's have sex I'm like you
know what lady I do pew and for some
reason for some reason you want you want
all of this right here yeah all four
eyes and everything if I remember
correctly there was I think some hush
money that was paid to them and it was
ad money yeah and it was I think Anthony
Bourdain was the one who paid for it
yeah yeah so I don't know man it just I
don't know the details of it again this
is just like [ __ ] that I read about I
don't know them personally I don't know
the intimate details of the relationship
but it just kind of makes you think and
I'm only talking about this because I
[ __ ] love Anthony Bourdain and rest
in peace he's a [ __ ] legend but he
just makes you think like how much of if
girl is kind of crazy like that so that
70 year old kid got his dick sucked and
got money allegedly I guess that's I
think that's what you know has been
reported how [ __ ] dare they do that
here rather than you sucking busy
getting money it's I'm up Walt I'm
appalled that an attractive woman had
sex with him and gave him money no I'm
[ __ ] around
it's all it's all dependent on the
person's experience yes 17 oral David
would have been like they're like here
have this is hush money on that one can
you do I wasn't expecting that
I would ham it up though I'm like you
know what I do need this money I get I
got it much you know the stress from it
I have PTSD from it all the time you
suck my [ __ ] it's so chewy how would I
told all my friends out him in my yo bro
I got 17 thousand dollars in a [ __ ]
can you [ __ ] believe it
can you [ __ ] believe and I had sex on
a yeah and nobody would believe me like
no you would know you did and she gave
you money man you're [ __ ] lying son
of a [ __ ]
no I'm just saying I'm just wondering
like if that played a part in to you
know Anthony Bourdain's final moments of
like you know what he was thinking and
we so there was a comic that recently
committed suicide - uh-huh
everybody knows who he is for me not so
much because I didn't hear a lot of his
denim but I do know his face because he
was in the The Hangover I believe in the
hangover yeah do you know who this actor
is let me see
Brody Stephens Brody Stephens no you
know if you see Brody Stephens face
you'll recognize him
uh-huh but I guess like in the comic
world he's like known as the [ __ ] uh-huh
but Brody Stephens committed suicide
like if you see his face you might know
who he is like he looks familiar but he
wasn't The Hangover I don't remember but
Brody Stephens yeah you know the way
comics talk about him they say he's like
one of the greats
really and so I guess like his suicide
kind of came surprising to a lot of this
was only recently like Joe Rogan was
talking about it motley everybody was
absolutely shocked that he killed
himself like that's the type of person
that
he grabbed the mic he commanded the room
uh-huh and it's kind of surprising how
how a lot of these celebrities are just
starting to just off themselves yeah man
I mean Kate Spade yeah Anthony Bourdain
Robin Williams not Brody Stevens yeah I
mean that's the scary thing you know
they might appear completely normal on
the outside sometime even be the
brightest lights but once that light
burns out inside of them you know you
might not be able to see it but that's
ultimately the end result right that
happens they take their own life and
imagine how dark of a place you need to
get into where you think all the
thoughts that you have all the problems
that you have the best way to solve it
is by ending your life you know because
I'm sure these people do think about the
people that they're gonna affect whether
it's their own family or their friends
or whoever right yet even still and
maybe sometimes it's not even that much
contemplating maybe it's just like an
instant thing we're like I'm done and
then they just on a whim decide to end
their life right now it's not sitting
there and you're brewing and it's like
yeah yeah should I do this or you know
if I do this what are the pros and cons
it's just one day you're just at such a
low point you're not even thinking
rationally and you're just like [ __ ] it
I'm over it yeah it's weird because you
know when Robin Williams killed himself
I would have never expected that man you
do it yeah especially for some reason I
feel like with comics like I don't
expect it from comics just because like
it within the comic toolbox is to make
fun of and make light of a lot of dark
situations yeah you would think that
they would they would be able to handle
that the most just because I feel like
as a comic you you kind of go through a
lot of things but you have a very in my
personal way like by joking about it you
have a very healthy way with dealing
with a lot of negative thoughts yeah so
maybe sometimes it just becomes too much
yeah I mean I feel like if anything you
know based on what you said that makes
it even harder for a comic because that
they're always joking and laughing
and and making other people laugh and
there's bringing so much joy and light
heartedness to the world but if they
have depression or just their demons
inside right when they're joking about
it just comes off as a joke you know
they could they could talk about it on
their stand-up sets like dark thoughts
that they might have but at the end of
the day it's within the context of a
joke right and so I think that might
shock people more because you're like oh
man that person was so funny and and so
lively and so animated and then they
killed themselves why right yeah but
that's the thing it's like whether
you're a comic or just the average Joe
if you have your demons and you have
that depression I it's it's not it's
gonna affect you it's not gonna matter
that there's no there's no I guess
criteria for who gets depression and who
doesn't you know you could be the
richest most famous person in the world
and to everybody outside looking at your
life
it might seem perfect but if you have
that within you that darkness I mean
nobody could really understand that and
maybe not even see it yeah cuz I I can't
really wrap my head around it because I
don't know yes like yeah like for me I
could just sit on a beach butt naked and
have a [ __ ] turtle right on top of my
lap and I could stare at the ocean for
six hours a day I'd be pretty [ __ ]
happy huh you know yeah so you know I
guess like in those times when people
are by themselves that's probably where
it broods the most yeah cuz when I'm by
myself and I'm just like let's say I'm
on a beach somewhere yeah and it's just
the perfect [ __ ] weather yeah and I'm
looking at into this this green crisp
blue ocean I ain't thinking about [ __ ]
yeah like I'm literally thinking about
nothing yeah I could keep my mouth open
and collect flies in my mouth if I
wanted to like that's how little I'm
thinking I mean iemon I'm a pretty
optimistic person
but I'm not gonna lie I mean there there
have definitely been moments where my
thoughts kind of go into a dark place
right not not to the point where like
you know I'm gonna take my own life but
you know sometimes you just kind of get
into a really dark place and
I Dexter I remember used to call it his
Dark Passenger do you remember that oh
yeah yeah except the first four seasons
yeah it was up to the Trinity Killer
yeah after that it's like what [ __ ] bro
and the ending Oh Mike so stupid so
[ __ ] stupid
but anyway I do have a sense of that to
where I do feel like sometimes and it'll
come out of nowhere like things could be
fine or even things going well and then
they'll just feel like kind of there's a
dark cloud around everything and it'll
just not feel that great maybe it's like
a small semblance of what depression
feels like and so I imagine that when I
have those feelings or those thoughts
it's just exaggerated infinitely you
know that that's what it must be like
for people to get to the point where
they're like I can't do this anymore you
know is so have you like sat around and
thought about like dying well I I do
think about dying just in general
because I think about death all the time
I don't I don't think about me being the
yeah yeah yeah yeah like I think about
okay what if I died yeah who would miss
me yeah and if somebody comes to my
funeral that I don't want there I'm
gonna haunt the [ __ ] out of them dude I
think about [ __ ] like that well I think
about death from I just a curiosity
standpoint yeah you know like I'm
curious about so many things I mean when
I think about death it's more so of I
wonder what the afterlife is like you
know because I'm a man of faith and so I
believe that after we leave this earth
like our that's not our final
destination
you know our death isn't our final
destination that's the beginning to the
next chapter so that's what I wonder
about like I wonder what it's like you
know I wonder if it's like big titties
and big booty [ __ ] dude that's what
I'm happy God welcomes you at the pearly
gates like Dave we got [ __ ] double
D's hey 80 years and you made you people
laugh and feeling good about themselves
here's a fat titty [ __ ] is one of them
my wife
probably not but enjoy this wallet laugh
and just smother your face into it ago
rub a bum ski yeah just really laughs
but yeah I mean I I definitely do have
like you know dark thoughts from time to
time but nothing on that extreme level
so yes it's hard for me to understand
fully what a person who's going through
that the thoughts that they're having
and the feelings and emotions that
they're having but I think I have like a
very very small idea of what it might be
like and then if I imagine that's just
being bigger and bigger and bigger and
just kind of growing and not going away
because yeah when those when those
feelings come up when there's no reason
to feel shitty right when everything is
cool everything is fine and all of a
sudden the light is just a little bit
dimmer it just feels a little bit dimmer
so just imagine it's like a bright and
sunny day outside and you're like
there's 75 degree weather is perfect
right and then out of nowhere just a
dark cloud kind of covers that sunlight
a little bit and you're like what the
[ __ ] happened why did it get so gloomy
but then that gloom kind of puts you in
a certain mood like no [ __ ] I don't
really see no depression I don't know I
don't know IIIi don't think I would go
as far as saying it's depression but
there are definitely moments throughout
throughout life in general where I have
those but that that feeling where it's
just that's pretty normal though yeah a
lot of people feel that stuff but yeah
when sometimes when I talk to so for
example a lot of people do message me
when they talk about my offing
themselves yeah oh wow that's [ __ ]
heavy they message you what for like
like DM like give me a reason to live
type [ __ ] stuff like that or they're
thinking about suicide or kind of they
say stuff like while I was going to kill
myself but I saw some of your videos at
home you laughing it made me feel better
oh [ __ ] I think like the the hard part
is it's weird because I'm you're coming
from somebody who has never thought
about killing himself like I've never
even entertained that thought yeah I
killing like if I like I think about if
I kid because I'm thinking okay well why
haven't you thought about killing
yourself because I would do a disservice
to the world
I need to live I need to live for
everybody else to see but narcissistic
is funny helps keep you alive right
whatever keep whatever keeps me going
dude people will tell me go kill
yourself I can't do that I can't I can't
do that to you yeah I can never I could
never do that to you you leave me here
if I die what are you gonna do with your
life come on buddy
but I always tell people you know the
the thing that may or may not help you
out is that what you're going through
everybody else goes through as well yeah
you know it's just how you're dealing
with it tends to be the the bigger issue
so when somebody says to me well I feel
like my life isn't worth anything cause
like people feel that all the time you
see I feel that too sometimes yeah I
don't think about killing myself as the
option to solve that problem right I try
to find value in my life and move
forward like ie for example this podcast
when people when I started doing this
podcast people told me that's a very bad
move you're averaging like 150,000 to
200,000 views per video whenever the
podcast is gonna drop and it did I lost
like 10,000 subscribers you sons of
[ __ ] hey sign the [ __ ] back up guys
you guys know it's genius brain now it's
David so man it was like I wasn't here
for this I'm here for some other [ __ ]
yeah like that's cool that's that's your
choice I'm gonna kill myself no no but I
they you know I I make these choices
because I wanted to make a change
because what I was doing before wasn't
making me happy yeah and maybe what
you're going through is probably what
I'm going through but how I deal with it
is different right it was it was a weird
space for me number one I did the film
the film was fun it was a highlight of
my life and I tried to do acting and I'm
still doing acting now but I had to
figure out what makes me tick and the
reason and I did that with the film I
was like well making a film right now is
gonna make me tick so when I decided to
do this film I didn't think about
getting the Sundance the first time who
the [ __ ] does yeah who the [ __ ] think
your first film that you ever are a part
of we're gonna help create you're gonna
get into Sundance like winning the
lottery yeah that's not gonna happen and
it did yeah so after that happened I was
kind of left in a weird space I was like
okay whoa what do i do no yeah he felt
good I was trying to make that a pipe
dream like the next five six years
I'll eventually get into a Sundance Film
yeah and it happened instantly yeah so I
sat there i didn't prepare what was
gonna happen after and i had to go back
to youtube and and i didn't want to go
back to youtube because i wanted to do
something bigger than that space and
mind you I was still creating content
but it didn't make me feel happy yeah so
I've been in those spaces where I'm like
I don't know what to do with my life
yeah and the first thing I did I try to
grab control of small things right so I
lost weight I started to work on TV
shows work on different stuff outside of
film and then you know we sold the the
Thriller show yeah to uh you know
attended yeah and that was that kind of
checked off that [ __ ] list yeah I'm
on to the next one now it's my next goal
so in the next coolest is podcast yeah
and I think that's really important man
for you to just set goals for yourself
in terms of things to look towards to
and to work towards right I think a lot
of times when people are in these dark
spots in their life they just have no
will to live they can't find the reason
to live they can't find something that
fulfills them or that makes them happy
or whatever and you can try to talk to
them but at the end of the day it really
comes down to you you got to find that
what you got to find that thing that
makes you tick that makes you want to
push yourself and keep living and keep
trying right because I could imagine the
same thing where like if I don't have
something that I'm passionate about that
I'm pursuing I don't know how great my
will to want to live would be you know
what I mean
like but that's always been present in
my life like there was always something
that fulfilled me in that I was
passionate about yeah that I wanted to
work towards and that always pushes me
but then if you don't have that in your
life and you're just in a spot where you
feel like nothing matters I can
understand how it might devolve into a
very very dark but man just [ __ ] just
[ __ ] think you're the [ __ ] all the
time and you'll never want to kill
yourself like it's almost damn near
impossible for me I'm like yeah I can't
die right now yeah yeah I guess I got
too much [ __ ] to do yeah
you know I I uh I mean arguably I feel
like before I die I'm not I'm never
going to be able to do everything that I
wanted
mmm I think for me that's the sad part
it's like okay like for example I want
to be really great at more time you want
to be really great at Jiu Jitsu yeah be
really great at MMA yeah I also want to
learn how to do clay pottery and then I
want to learn how to build a mud hut at
the out of a middle of nowhere I want to
become a bush man I want to make a fire
with my bare hands a lot of things I
want to do nothing to do with making
money
yeah just things that you're interested
in that's a crappy thing my goals have
nothing to do with money
yeah and somehow I'm trying to make
money off of it yeah you know well I
mean that's like you and the present
right below you in the past cuz I think
I could say that when I was younger and
more immature have I entertained the
idea of like taking my own life just on
the most superficial level on the
surface level right just what if I did
that right on that level yeah for sure
but not to the point where it goes
beyond that like oh I'm really gonna
consider this as an option and like how
I'm gonna do it dude I can't even give
myself a paper cut I couldn't imagine
slitting my wrists or like jumping off
somewhere
dude recently to I'm not sure if this
person killed themselves but we just
shot a sin foods episode and Smorgasburg
LA and a Smorgasburg Ellie apparently
somebody fell off a building and diet OH
as I left so right after I learned after
same day same day oh [ __ ] it was either
the parking lot building or building
around it somebody fell off and they
died and so people are saying it was
suicide uh-huh for me I'm assuming that
somebody tried to take a really cool
selfie and they fell off I assume just
because who killed himself that's my
[Laughter]
food and their life so I'm thinking
maybe it was an accident or something
but it's kind of crazy just that that
thought that somebody did that yeah
that's it's it's a dark ship man and I
and I feel like like you said it's it's
having those dark moments is something
that everybody goes through but for some
people it just becomes a little bit more
extreme and unfortunately sometimes yeah
it does get to the point where they take
their own life and then they do
something that drastic but I just think
it's so important that if you are in
that moment she
try to reach out to people you know just
just try to at least talk to the people
that are close to you if you don't have
anybody close in your life which camera
I'm gonna give you a situation right now
well I'm a depressed person I'm gonna
see how you handle it okay cuz I think
this is this is like stuff legit that
I've heard people say and I have and I
have the hardest time dealing with yeah
yeah just because now I'm not a
therapist but I'm gonna try to you know
okay yeah I want to kill myself why do
you want to kill yourself because I hate
your face I can't change my face that's
what I was born with I'm dying tomorrow
then what are you gonna do about it
I for your sake so that you continue to
live I will stop showing my face for a
while well you did a good job
you really should be a therapist I will
give people the will to live no but I
mean that's man I could only imagine
what that's like to be in that position
where you're trying to help people who
are genuinely thinking about killing
themselves and if they do end up doing
that how can you not feel that burden
you know how can you not feel that I
wish some of these celebrities kind of
and I'm pretty sure they knew it too it
is probably a bigger factor to why they
maybe they ended up killing themselves
because of maybe a lot of social
pressures too yeah absolutely because
the hard part about this is when a
celebrity kills themselves everybody
sees it
everybody does it yet it's plastered
everywhere yeah and there's an in my
personal opinion and I think there's
like some Studies on it right now when
there's a negative ripple effect that's
happening where a lot of these younger
people are looking at these celebrities
who are offering themselves and they're
saying well if they can't do it like how
come what am I supposed to do this guy
who has arguably on a superficial level
everything that anybody desires yeah
talking about money we're talking about
travel the big house respect we're
talking about legacy in Robin Williams
case he has legacy he is somebody who
even after he dies people will be
talking about it for hundreds and
hundreds and thousands all as the human
civilization is around it will be and
that's something that I wanted yeah and
if that person doesn't find value in his
life
who what am i yeah and that's the part
that scares me right as Robin Williams
then Kate Spade yeah now Brody Stevens
yeah so it's it's you know is are they
becoming a catalyst for people to say
well if they did it I can do it now -
yeah that's and that is a scary thing
because it it becomes a reasonable
option you know because you're seeing it
you're hearing about it and before maybe
it wasn't it was like I shouldn't think
about stuff like that yeah but then you
see it more and more being talked about
on the news or whatever when when these
celebrities do take their own life and -
just some regular ass teenager or person
somewhere out there in the world they
see that like you said and it's like oh
[ __ ] I mean they had a great life and
they couldn't handle it my life and that
isn't even a fraction of what their life
is and I feel like this [ __ ] it you know
and if people want to talk about I guess
I guess one way that people can really
just think about it in a positive light
is that there are people with a lot less
than them mm-hmm and they're always
happy yeah man yeah that and that's I
guess the hard part for these people who
are going through these things is for
them to try to focus on the good things
and their lasses always half-empty
exactly exactly
and that's really hard to change their
point of view and make them think that
the glass is actually half-full right
and it just kind of reminds me of even
like these mass murders who go on these
mass shootings they see how much
attention that previous mass shooters
got on the news yeah and the it becomes
somewhat glamorized in their mind like
oh [ __ ] if I do this then I could get
that type of coverage - yes I think
that's kind of like almost a disservice
by the news outlets they need to be more
responsible about how they go about
reporting this type of stuff and how
much coverage they give to this stuff
I'm not saying that it's not important
but at the same time it they know I mean
they do it because it [ __ ] brings in
money for them it gives them viewership
s'right people they want to instill fear
and fear is always a great tack
for people to pay attention to get
people to pay attention and that's why
they do it they talk about it all the
news outlets will cover it if there's a
mass shooting but really giving this
person a name right this this mass
shooting a killer and and like their
background and where they they're what
their family was like it's like dude why
do they [ __ ] deserve that type of
attention you know just report on it one
time and just leave it alone right and
and and I'm not saying that to
disrespect the people who lost their
lives in situations like that all I'm
saying is you're not doing society a
favor by giving attention to these
people because all the other crazy [ __ ]
out there who were looking at that or
thinking that could be me you know and
if I do this I could be that person dude
remember when that whole what's it call
was it the Columbine shooter
right he was the one that was doing all
the different poses with the gun no no
no no that was the MIT the Virginia Tech
the Virginia Tech yeah the Asian kid
right there oh so sad what he's Korean
oh my god because when that [ __ ] came
out I was like that's a white boy if I
ever heard one and next thing you know
this kid gun poses me and I was like god
damn it dude why Korean man and you had
to do those poses on top of that yeah
man he look like a little anime we
banned [ __ ] I love anime you make it
anime look bad bro like dude man and
then he yo he was he was somebody that
was bullied too wasn't he yeah I think
like people severely bullied him dude
man I heard so many bad cases of
bullying just from other people because
yeah that was bullying in my school too
but it didn't happen as often as I think
other schools did because usually if you
kind of kept to yourself things didn't
really happen to you yeah so if for
example you know categorically speaking
if the Nerds kind of just hung out with
the Nerds and I want one of them yeah
nothing happened yeah to us right he's
kind of chilled out you know and all
somebody who floated between groups so I
I could witness this [ __ ] like if you
didn't say [ __ ] nothing happened right
so arguably for me I loved hanging out
with some of the geekier people because
it was so nice maybe they just they just
were themselves it was so awesome being
it was very awesome and refreshing but
every time I try to hang out with people
that I grew up with
and they tend to be a little more
thuggish I felt like I had to put on a
show Yeah right but what happens with
that is that when you're when you kind
of hang out with a group like that
they're just problems will arise yeah
but if you kind of kept your mouth shut
nothing would really happen but when I
was in college I noticed not notice I
there's this guy that was in my dorm he
went to San Diego and it was a
predominantly like white school that he
went to I used to get bullied all the
[ __ ] time yeah like he told me this
one time when he was going back to
school these do chased him down and he
[ __ ] just chucked him into a [ __ ]
bush like [ __ ] like that what happened
yeah and that was something that just
wasn't happening in my area so much you
know unless they were gonna rob you
which wasn't bullying this is you walk
into a bad neighborhood yeah you know
yeah so that whole bullying concept to
makes me wonder like yell maybe that kid
could have been the next guy that was
gonna flip out and kill some mother a
witch for him when I did see him I
didn't have a feeling of like oh this
kid my flipped out so I'm gonna be his
best friend so while he's shooting up a
play he's like you know what David
you're okay and he's gonna move past me
but yo dude he would tell me some crazy
stories I was just one of many I can't
remember a lot of them but that was the
one that stuck out to me the most of
hinge is walking to school yeah and
somebody would just Chuck him into a
bush yeah that reminds me of this has
nothing to do with bullying but when you
said flip out I just remind me of this
this kid I knew he would always like
have some sort of proposition for you
you know and and then he would offer to
do something ridiculous in exchange for
like 50 cents or a dollar or whatever
it's wrong with this guy I don't know
but dick look a quarter man I thought I
thought I tell you what I'll tell you
like in a nutshell what this guy was he
got a teacher fired because the teacher
said something I guess distasteful about
Native Americans and he said his
background he has Native American blood
in him and so he wrote a letter to the
district you know talking about this and
how it offends him and you know this
it's disgraceful for a history teacher
you know to be I guess that insensitive
about something like that and then years
later aterna
he's not even Native American what the
[ __ ] is a psychopath yeah he's like
Middle Eastern
what the hell no no but one time dude
it's like what's your dad last name ala
body's um one time one time governor
Gray Davis he was the Governor of
California at the time he was coming to
our school to speak right and this guy
was like hey and any talk like this
hain't Andric um you know do you need
anything done and can you give me a
dollar for it you know and I was like
thinking in my head what's the most
ridiculous thing I could I could think
of right and I was like oh [ __ ] governor
Gray Davis is coming to the school and I
told him hey if you attack over there
great day I said it thinking like that's
so ridiculous absurd yeah it's absurd
that he's not even gonna okay I was like
you gonna do it he's like yes it's like
okay so we had like the assembly and he
spoke uh-huh and then afterwards
everybody kind of came out and then
Governor Davis was like shaking
everybody's hand you know the students
hands and I'm talking to them right I
see this fool like sneaking through the
crowd right and I'm like oh [ __ ] this
was actually about to do so yes a paper
clip in a rubber back he was pulling it
back trying to shoot that guy I don't
know he did it
okay but thank God he didn't [ __ ] didn't
even like know I did it I was like he's
like hey Adric so you know can I get my
dog like not bro you didn't you didn't
even touch himself you you failed to
meet your end of the bargain
you know dude there's some dude there
are so many weird people in high school
man there's this one guy I remember he
was just he was that white dude that
always wore the [ __ ] Martha Francis
Garbo Jesus [ __ ] for like a hundred
bucks it's super expensive right but
this dude always want that extra baggy
clothes
stills name was Keith now this fool
Keith was you should always stir up [ __ ]
in class like if if he's supposed to do
something the teacher would tell him to
do he would do the exact opposite yeah
and it got to a point where that teacher
specifically got so [ __ ] fed up with
them
she just ejected this full out of class
just get the [ __ ] out of my class get
out right and he goes man [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and he gets up but he forgot to tighten
his belt this is a saggy pet and his
[ __ ] pants fell down to his ankles he
gets up BAM boxers everything dog
I started dying laughing dude and only a
few people saw it because you know
people are being really studious yeah
but the people who caught it couldn't
stop laughing but me I was heaving yeah
like just screaming laughing right and
so she looked at me and I was really
cool with her but she was so fed up with
his [ __ ] yeah she sent me outside - she
was David - get out and I got outside
and then I was out there and when she
came back outside so he left he just
left campus and she looked at me and ice
was still laughing and she was what is
so funny
and as I'm dying laughing I'm explained
- what happened dude she starts cracking
the [ __ ] up me and her and laughing
together outside people wonder like yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on she just
walked back in just dying laughing
together I didn't get in trouble because
she knew how ridiculous it was yeah that
was such a [ __ ] Trump he was so weird
he was like one of those dudes that
consistent hung out with only black
people so he was that one white dude in
a group of black people okay so he had
the [ __ ] earring in his ear he had
the extra baggy pants and he was always
starting up like [ __ ] for no reason like
a reasonable dude I think he just wanted
to be something that he wasn't yeah man
that reminds me of a time when I fell to
the ground laughing so we were in class
and then I don't know if you guys had
this after school but we had this thing
called a gold-card right and the gold
card like you would buy it fraud on the
20 bucks and it would be partnered with
like local businesses and so it give you
discounts when you show that part no
yeah so anyway one of my friends had one
of those gold cards right and then
somebody asked him if they could take a
look at it and then he's like yeah yeah
to him they're looking at it okay cool
and then this person gave it to another
person because that person wants to look
at it right he looks at it and then
maybe like five minutes later he's like
where's my gold card right and then the
guy who had it last is like I don't have
it he said what do you mean you don't
have it like you were the person who
were looking was looking at it last
right yeah he's like well I don't have
it I don't I don't know what happened to
it then my friend gets up from his desk
and he's like because we called his guy
the Hulk because he [ __ ] flips and
when he flips he goes somewhere else
there's no rationality right and then he
gets in front of his desk he walks up to
him he's like where the [ __ ] is my gold
card right and he's like it has had it
is basically like the guy keeps saying I
don't have it and then my friend just
[ __ ] snaps he [ __ ] [ __ ] back boom
slap some [ __ ] heart as hard as he
can across it and he's not as small my
friend is like maybe about your size a
little bit shorter but he's not a small
dude you know slaps his fool across the
face his [ __ ] glasses flew to the
other side of the classroom and then I
was sitting like right behind
I looked for a moment and then I just
[ __ ] fell to the ground crack cuz it
was so ridiculous you know like the act
of seeing somebody gets slapped like
that in the club and the funny [ __ ] was
we had a substitute teacher that day
yeah oh just okay just just why don't
you calm down just just sit back in your
seat okay it's is it just calm everybody
calm down it's okay he didn't know how
to respond to the situation I was just
[ __ ] on the floor roll it I was like
oh my god so did he get his gold card
back no he never found it but he got
suspended for like a week so not only
did he get it not get his gold card back
I do that slap in the [ __ ] you guys
slept in the [ __ ] face man did they
definitely stole it from yeah well I
mean there's a thing it's like dude all
right if you see this dude getting this
riled up about something that small yeah
just [ __ ] give it back to him you
know it's not gonna go anywhere Pleasant
you know what he's like
pounding at your desk
ask you've heard back just give it back
to him but I was like well you had it
comin bro let's go in the same class
after you would not be able to mean the
same oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's really
uncomfortable yeah but you know it's
like I think the dude learned his lesson
don't ever take somebody's gold card man
he slapped the [ __ ] taste out of his
[ __ ] glasses flew across the room bro
I was like dude I love high school
fights man high school fights were one
of those fights that just there's no
real consequences because it was a fool
depends man well I mean like you know in
real life if you're outside in the
street you slap the living [ __ ] out of
somebody want to jail you're going to do
okay okay in that sense yeah in high
school you slap somebody you get
offended yeah
worse that could happen maybe you get
kicked out if it's really really bad
maybe you get arrested but yeah yeah
those are the good old days man when
like if you ever wanted to get into a
fistfight doing high school right now
he's good in high school get it out of
your system you know get it out of your
system in elementary school junior high
and high school because the consequences
are way less severe you get what after
school suspension okay let me ask you
distance oh sorry I didn't mean to cut
you off but do you think that as a guy
anyway that you should get into a fight
in your life at some point it depends so
I used to say yes uh-huh
I don't think I wouldn't say per se that
you should get into a fight I think you
should get the [ __ ] slapped out of you
once in your life mm-hmm because it does
put in perspective that there's always
somebody bigger than you out there that
can Punk you so be careful about what
you do to somebody else so from from
that standpoint damn I think my these
are the grapes and the stems dude they
saw the The Grapes of Wrath the adesh it
was like being outlined as [ __ ] we're
gonna have to what's it called crop this
and lift it up later damn do I not leave
it alone bro let him see it man like
hold in this room dude that's just extra
small it's not like that you didn't let
me preflop first if I fill up that [ __ ]
is huge it's like yeah why is my pant
area so tight oh that's right I got
these these [ __ ] compressions
you just realize this now yeah I just
scratched my balls and I rub my nose
that's nice i'ma cross my legs real
quick um but going back to it for me I
think so I think I think as a guy that
you should fight at some point in your
younger life just because you should
know what it feels like to hit somebody
and to get hit back you know and and
part of that is I guess the the lesson
you just brought up is is knowing when
to kind of know your place and not get
so ridiculous right because somebody
will check your ass and beat your beat
your ass if you get out of line but
another thing is just I don't know man I
just feel like it's call most like a
rite of passage into becoming a man you
know to have been in a physical fight
and and not necessarily win right if you
win that's great too but I just don't
want my kid to be a confrontational
human being yeah yeah not like that
because I grew up way to confrontation
yeah you know I had a [ __ ] mouthpiece
on me yeah so I think arguably a lot of
the reasons why I got I got into a fight
there was two factors right it wasn't
one because somebody was doing something
to a friend so out of loyalty I just had
to jump in oh yeah which was so [ __ ]
annoying because I'm like but I have to
know I I took it upon myself like dude I
I've been fighting since I was like in
first grade no joke like physical
fistfights with people since I was in
first grade I know I didn't like it yeah
no I I didn't even think about it like
dude one time I think in third grade
right this kid kicked my friend in the
balls right for no reason but north no
[ __ ] reason right and obviously that
[ __ ] was painful and my friend went down
and he started crying and [ __ ] and I
looked at that dude and I was like you
just [ __ ] wait you have another thing
coming out right and then um I forget it
feels like the same day or later that
week I was playing a ball in my
neighborhood and this fool made the
mistake of riding his bike down my block
and I and I stopped and I saw how old
are you third grade probably like 9 what
a violent little child you when I was
like you [ __ ] up coming into my block
right now and then he was riding by I
threw my basketball at him like on his
head he fell off his bike
and I got on top of him and I just
started [ __ ] going off on him [ __ ]
broke his glasses his nose is all bloody
I started like there were cars stopped
in the middle of the street because I
was in the middle of the street just
pounding on it right one of them was my
friends uncle he got the crazy whoopee
what are you doing you know like stop
maybe about 15 minutes later is this a
white kid his parents came to my my my
house mhm
I started open the door open the door
right now and then my mom opens the door
she had no idea she didn't know that I
just did if this kid is sitting here
face all [ __ ] up and his your kid did
this to my son we're gonna get him
expelled from school and all this not
exciting well jokes I do my kids stupid
he's gonna get expelled either way my
mom was yeah I actually did get kicked
outta school later that year my mom was
like why did you do I think he kicked my
friend in the boss bomb went off on the
guy did you know what you're gay no so
like I always you know I had to avenge
my friends man I didn't even think twice
about my dude you [ __ ] I I told you we
talked about this on the podcast before
friends and family man there's a line
there don't cross it with me
I want my kid just to be a witness just
this [ __ ] this I do man I saw you get
beat up bro ok ok like that I want I
wanted to step in but you know them cops
yeah I mean I can't do nothing that's
that's what I want to be oh I just hated
that stuff too I always felt like I had
to do it and a lot of the fights that
were picked was because somebody else
picked it for me and if it was up to me
I'm most likely I wouldn't have done
anything but I was a big guy I was this
size since I was 14 yeah so you know
when you grew up full of like well you
know the area that I grew up was
predominantly black and Asian like as
the Asian kid I was like the big Asian
kid in the group yes or sure so
obviously it's like okay well are you
gonna go throw down with this I'm like I
guess you know do I have to do I have to
it's like it's with a lot of the people
that were troublemakers
we're friends that I grew up with yeah I
met them later like most likely we
wouldn't have been Frank right but
because of that loyalty that you have
growing up on the same block yeah too
hether you feel like you have to I
always had to pretend like I was
something that I wasn't yes I hung out
with a lot of people who weren't great
people yeah but I wasn't really them
yeah I was the anime kid and I should
have been a [ __ ] anime kid but I will
say this is oh yeah because I went
through that experience and I hung out
with them they did help me grow a
[ __ ] backbone so when people did try
to Punk me it was a very different story
that's what I'm saying
because it's for that reason that I
think that as a boy you know on your way
to becoming a man that's something you
got to go through because if I have a
son I don't want him to be meek I don't
want him to be soft
I don't want him to like let people step
over them and stuff like that but when
you realize because I feel like a lot of
the times for people who have never been
punched in the face before that that
that's like the worst thing that can
happen in the world right like oh I
don't ever want to [ __ ] get hit but
once you take it and you get your lumps
and bruises you realize it's not that
bad you know
and it makes you feel a little bit
stronger a little bit more capable and
that's why I feel like they need to go
through that yeah it's weird too because
I think the way we grew up and during
the time that we grew up that's just
different time yeah gangster violence
was very glorified it's not now like
violence is not glorify yeah it's it's
it was hyper glorified when we grew up
yeah so you know when we when we recount
these stories some people are like oh so
you thought especially in my case oh you
thought you were a thug I'm like no
everybody got into a fight it was just
an average yeah like was there wasn't a
person who didn't get beat up yeah who
didn't get punched in the face who
didn't throw down yeah
that's not to say and that's the thing
to people who say that clearly never
grew up around any type of gangster
they're a whole [ __ ] life if you
think that just because you got into a
fight suddenly you think you're against
it clearly shows that you never grew up
exactly man like getting beat up and
you're having like throwing fists
doesn't mean you're a tough guy it was a
way of survival peers just try to rob
you they try to beat you up yeah for any
[ __ ] reason so you had to fight back
it just happens yes happened there's
nothing to do with trying to be a thug
or a tough guy it was just either I
consistently get beat up or I have to at
least swing trying yeah you know yeah
it's just it's just is what it was at a
time yeah no for sure yeah and that's
what I'm saying he's like dude I
remember first time I got jump second
grade dude second [ __ ]
great I was fighting this kid right and
then another one of his friends came and
they joint and then they basically got
me on the ground started like punching
me kicking me whatever I remember bro I
remember this very specifically there
was this super quiet kid right I
remember his name Joe Voki shoutout to
Joe Buki if you're watching this
somewhere I probably haven't seen you in
like [ __ ] 20-some years but I think
you sound like a [ __ ] yugioh card no
but this kid was like super quiet and
shy right and I think like some some
kids made fun of him because of that but
I was always cool with them I never
liked him no problems or whatever this
fool comes out of nowhere bro and he
just [ __ ] starts going off on this on
the kids who were jumping me and then
that allowed me to get me back up on my
feet and I started going after them
house like oh [ __ ] thanks Joe and then
it turned out his dad was a boxer so his
he was trained his dad was training him
so he's let people yeah you [ __ ] lit
them up like out of nowhere I was like
my [ __ ] angel he just walks away with
a cigarette lid in his mouth I think he
was like like the Tongan or something
like that it was probably 7 feet tall at
the age of 6 yeah I remembered like his
hairstyle too man he had that MacGyver
cut he had the spikes and in the [ __ ]
mullet in the back how old are you at
this time 2nd grade and he was second
grade - yeah he was second grade Ozzie I
don't remember
7 feet tall minimum 300 pounds and he
had he had 3 kids of his own but yeah
that dude lit those kids of and I was
like weird a [ __ ] that I didn't even
express it was like after recess
everybody had gone class our kids would
jump you for no [ __ ] reason back in
India I got jumped on my way back home
from Isabel Jackson elementary school
because when we were waiting outside in
line and I did like this yo mama joke on
this dude that hurt his feelings so
[ __ ] bad because you know people were
cracking up and [ __ ] and cuz I had a
mouthpiece on me even when I was younger
just because I had to be like I was such
a do we be looking kid yeah if I didn't
if I wasn't sharp with my [ __ ] words
I would get Punk'd all the time yeah so
the least I could do was just clown on
somebody so you know I'm a fundable with
some kind of are [ __ ]
very sad little yo mama joke but it made
people laugh huh and so this will jump
me after school with his uh with his
friends and I remember because his full
Chuck a [ __ ] rock in my head and I
was like oh side of my head and so when
I was going home there was this kid
named Jason he was like a Korean friend
of ours his dad was at home he came out
and I remember he grabbed the kid
anytime just [ __ ] started cursing at
him in Korean he shook the [ __ ] came
in chucked his ass home to go home and
then you put ice pack on my hand yeah
and so the whole time I was just [ __ ]
fuming and kid and so the next day I
went to go find them like individually
so they couldn't jump me yeah so I
started whaling on this kid in the
cafeteria yeah just [ __ ] just
pummeling him at the back of his head so
he started crying of course I was a big
kid then to the other kids just jets and
I [ __ ] follow him all the way into
the bathroom next to the wall ball yeah
so there's a bat we have a wall ball
area and the next to it is the boys
bathroom I followed him into the [ __ ]
bathroom
uh-huh I literally tackled him I just
started kicking him in the face
literally started just kicking him in
the face and just start stopping on his
face and then we went to the office and
you know the funny thing about kids are
after that whole ordeal first of all
there was three kids I don't got to beat
up two of them after the whole ordeal we
went to the office and this is what the
[ __ ] says to me I will remember
this till this day he goes hey let's
just say that we were just joking around
and playing and we were friends yeah
because you don't ever want to be asked
out you know that hey like you're
thinking of I what's what's the most
reason yeah we're just joking around and
we're just we're friends and I was like
no I'm not saying that [ __ ] at all yeah
[ __ ] jump me look at this look at the
lump on my [ __ ] head yeah you know
but then you know at that time I usually
a bullied a lot so it wasn't it wasn't
out of the ordinary that something like
that would happen it's just the only
difference was is that was that
immigrant kid that came from Korea huh
huh but I was a big kid and I had K rage
you you you were that kid that everybody
wanted you to play Center but man you
too big you got a guard I'm shooting all
day baby
give me that J I'm shooting that J but I
hated that [ __ ] because like my dad was
very specific about me not getting into
trouble but at the same time my dad told
me you know if they're bullying you and
you're putting hands on you just [ __ ]
beat them up yeah
because he understood that you know we
were I was an immigrant kid and I was
gonna get bullied and arguably if you
look at pictures of me and when I was a
kid yeah I should have gotten bullied
yeah like I would have bullied myself
you know yeah so I was just an easy
target because I was a nice goofy kid
yeah but at the same time I also was a
very large kid with a very very short
temper yeah and anytime I could use tech
quando I wanted to use that [ __ ] on
somebody dude I want back straight kick
the kid in a stomach and he launched his
ass my straight up launched him because
he was trying to tackle me okay so I
just did a spinning back straight kick
and I [ __ ] launched I remember how
satisfying that [ __ ] felt yeah good
that the fact that you actually landed
it right yeah but we we sparred all the
time as a kid so it was it was gonna
happen my pops is always like if I got
into a fight you know he wouldn't like
it but then it always asked did you win
yeah my dad used to do that [ __ ] when
you get beat up he will send you back
out to go fight them again
no cuz I've only do you know how many
fights you've lost in your life I know
exactly I lost two fights in my life I
have lost a lot I got beat up by this
other kid named Brian and like punched
me right in that area in your solar
plexus oh I got jumped in junior high
huh I got jumped a lot maybe I deserved
it who knows well I got jumped because I
stabbed this kid in third grade oh my
god up in junior high I still remember
that [ __ ] with the pencil the pencil so
you still have a scar on his face which
I don't know why he was so mad you look
like a cute dimple and but um yeah he
jumped me then
other than that I mean there was a
couple of other times too but I don't
know if his beat up because they were
group fights okay so you know you don't
know who's telling fisting right right
right
yeah now I got the two times that I lost
a fight in my book anyway is a first
time I think I was about like 9mm and
there was this junior high kid in my
neighborhood and he was racist as [ __ ]
right and so he would always like just
say these like racial slurs and like
racial comments and one day I basically
was like that's enough I'm gonna [ __ ]
punch this guy in the face and then get
my ass beat afterwards like I decided
with it
yeah cuz dude the dude was like twice my
size you know so like clearly he was
gonna out power me and what my ass once
I do it but I was like enough is enough
I'm gonna [ __ ] sock this guy and get
my ass beat afterwards and that's
exactly what Jordan committed to the
[ __ ] I committed to it you know [ __ ]
I'm just gonna see what happened so I I
got a you know I had to reach up to hit
him in the face and after I hit him
obviously he got pissed so you know he
messed me up and then he was so crazy
about getting your ass whooped you you
you're wondering what its gonna add ten
minutes god damn i funny guys but you
know what though we got cool after that
only I think it made him you know like
get respect for me because I was willing
to like stand up for myself even though
I was like so much younger and so much
smaller than him but we got cool after
that and then second time I think I was
about 11 and I was fighting this kid and
then we were throwing hands and then I
was like backing up and then I tripped
biggest mistake and then he got on top
of me and started whaling on me wow that
was happening I was a [ __ ] I had to Jeff
you know I was like trying to cover up
and then like I got [ __ ] all these
lumps on my head in my face and [ __ ] and
I was like man we gonna do that again
this time I'm gonna train and fighting
man it was it was literally out of
necessity I've never picked the fight
with somebody I never it was just like
either somebody would try to bully me or
when I got older it was out of loyalty
yeah so yeah so stupid man even till
this day when I go back to Sacramento
there's a specific friend that I still
kick it with us till this day yeah he
still has violent tendencies and because
of him I get riled up at this age at
this age he still gets riled up and I
don't like being around him because he
starts making he gets me through that
point yeah what are we doing what are we
getting mad at it's your fault like you
spilled your drink on him getting that
bad energy man it's infectious hey what
are you ready to go throw down on this
[ __ ] fried chicken
I'm not fighting about dude too old for
that [ __ ] dude way too old for this [ __ ]
and I was somebody now people recognize
me if I get beat up I'm not gonna be
known as a dude that got beat up in his
hometown not to mention and then a slap
on the wrist no more handcuffs on the
wrist now you know I can't survive in
jail
I got a nice ass dude people [ __ ] me so
bad [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's like an hour and
16 oh what a way to end a [ __ ] pocket
clench them butt cheeks that's the
lesson of this podcast keep it clenched
keep it tight
anyways guys your cute little bastards
that concludes this episode of genius
brain the most random podcast you listen
to we're just gonna be with you
throughout your whole day and Entertain
You man when you're working when you
just try a chill and kick it just get
some laughs in remember you can find
this on Spotify you guys find us on
cashbox stitch or iTunes podcast
whatever you're thinking of we're on
there I don't think SoundCloud but I
will see you guys next time
edge record can they find you Instagram
ed to secret society com check it out no
- uh for what Instagram no I oh no -
yeah but-but-but the actual name is - e
ISOs - you're a terrible friend stupid
when you just think - one [ __ ] thing
anyways guys see y'all next time